each team will have five minutes to
pitch everybody knows that they will
then have five minutes for questions and
answers after their pitch the 15 K
creative arts competition is for student
arts focused businesses so this is an
area of arts arts entrepreneurship that
tends to mix the Arts and Technology and
Sciences up in very interesting ways
well first of all I think MIT is just an
incredibly creative place there are so
many creative people here I remember as
a student just thinking that in a sense
art was everywhere the parameter for
applying is really just to have an idea
even if you're a solo entrepreneur
because after you apply there are six
weeks of mentoring and networking and
workshops so that at the end of April
that live pitch day you have a strong
business plan you've considered your
market you considered your past market
you considered your team your value prop
and all of the other things that an
important business has the mentorship
component really helped us rethink some
of our
the way we're presenting our ideas and
even some of our business model
questions that was really helpful I
think the most important thing is not
the reader the reader we're seeing a lot
of technological disruption in the arts
and MIT being a leader in technology it
just needs to be involved in in
supporting the arts from a technological
perspective
[Music]